hey everybody back again this is Jason
Schroeder the game director on South
Park the fractured but whole and with me
is hi I'm Kimberly Wiegand I'm an
Associate Producer on South Park the
fractured but whole fantastic so thanks
for coming back to us for part two of
our walkthrough of our demo last time
you would have seen us play through the
peppermint hippo were infiltrating here
with our friend Scott malkinson and
making our way through to find a missing
cat we're on the trail of a woman named
classy and we just got the information
out of two gentlemen here in the VIP
backroom of the strip clubs so we've
just won a combat and here we got some
some cool loot and on this walkthrough I
think we're gonna take people through
looting crafting some of the stuff that
you do besides fighting and giving men
lap dances in the game and a little bit
of a puzzle exploration as well I'm
gonna take all of this loot and maybe
buy a drink for the DJ next up on the
main stage we've got a little bit of hot
sauce coming up your way let's give it
up for every game and come out of that
back room no we need to find a way to
distract you we can mix that drink
psychic
recipes onstage - so Scott has figured
out very quickly how a strip club works
we're gonna make this DJ special drink
because what he's decided is that
whatever anyone says into that
microphone over there makes people
coming from the back room he's sort of
like a amazing summoning super person so
he really wants a gin and tonic and so
the next logical thing to do is try to
find this manage in a tonic and Spike it
yep and first stop is probably the bar
it seemed like a logical place to go for
a drink there's a gin and tonic right
there no problem so if we had an adult
levels of money we'd be able to buy this
but we are kids and have four dollars
and 79 cents even adult levels of money
that's an expensive trip clubs are
expensive expensive places so that's not
gonna work for us we have to find
another way to get it nice and check out
this back room and see if there's
anything just laying around yeah
I'll throw some firecrackers well it
shakes well another thing that's cool
about firecrackers in this game is they
can kind of light some stuff on fire
nothing works quite as well a good
respond oh that looks dangerous it's not
going off I don't need to add a little
gas to it effective
okay let's just see what this is
[Music]
I just wanted you guys to be able to
hear the whole song cool so looking
around we're gonna keep kind of
searching and looting and see if we find
ourselves
gin and tonic nothing yet just a can of
red balls he has some good components
but normal backroom stuff just some wine
cooler mix and a rat trap
I wasn't glue glue for crafting so our
recipe shows that we need a gin and
tonic something gross and something
gross okay so let's see what's this so
it looks like you're able to grab onto
that and move it around mmm all right so
you can use that to explore different
places higher places all right so that
first little treasure chest there did
not get us anything gross either but I'm
going to follow this these grease stains
and blend my way over to the freezer and
try to get up to that rat you can see an
inspection there with those little
cracks and glowing so that indicates
something is able to be messed with
there he's gonna let me hold on to the
gross stuff yeah all right so I got two
of the great ingredients but we still
need a gin and tonic so let's keep this
down here looks like
yes [ __ ] behind the bar booze booze
booze a bit more cash there's the
daycare oh yeah
in the last video one of the the
strippers told us too that the employee
daycares behind the bar and it was true
take that all right those are perfect
perfect prove you right all right so I'm
gonna craft the DJ special looks some
crafting points awesome as you craft
things in the game you rank up in order
to be able to craft better and better
items or or greater quantities I think
it's good enough but I think we have one
special power is the new kid one more
[ __ ] in a week and I put that drink back
up Scott gave us a little bit of his
backstory there as he says he was been
he's been crafting this backstory with
the [ __ ] we've all been working on our
backstories with the [ __ ] and in his
case his mom farted in his face during
childbirth which gave him diabetes or
the super strong but it's an ultimatum
reason or embarrassment basically like
Bruce Banner all right we're gonna give
this DJ cocktail really good the does
appreciate it I go back friend he just
wanted to drink the whole night hey
what'd you call the meow wait a minute
well it's alright we got her then she
ran away all right there's a couple of
cases of mistaken identity going on here
first we got mistaken for strippers and
now we're have been mistaken for our
powers of disguise so great we look
exactly like cops
all right let's make it back here oh
she's not in this room no but there are
some things to loot it looks like
there's some gold handles oh it's a lot
I guess we got ooh a new artist okay the
dazzling orb so artifacts are things you
can equip to get yourself stronger in
the game it's kind of like your
equipment but we didn't want you to have
to like change the way you look in order
to be stronger because this is your
superhero brand exactly yeah so so
artifacts are other kinds of items that
you can use
now let's I'm sure she's probably just
behind this door and it's going to come
quietly that's right oh absolutely yeah
absolutely we'll just talk it out yeah
[Music]
nobody's allowed back here yeah you want
to get to her you're gonna have to go
through us that sounds unpleasant yes
all right so we need to fight our way
through these ladies to get to classy
but we'll have to leave it on this
cliffhanger okay so thanks for tuning
into our videos yeah we hope you enjoyed
what you saw and we look forward to
sharing more about our game in the
future thanks everybody
hey available October 17th get the stick
of truth free with purchase pre-order
now for Towelie bonus content